Congress could soon take up new
legislation to help suicide prevention
programs Senate Democratic leader Chuck
Schumer is calling on the federal
government to increase funding and
create more resources resources rather
to reduce the number of suicide now this
comes after a CDC study found nearly
45,000 people died by suicide in 2016 it
is the tenth leading cause of death in
the United States the recent high
profile deaths of Kate Spade and Anthony
Bourdain sparked a national conversation
about mental health and suicide
prevention it's a topic we've covered
and will continue to discuss here on CBS
this morning
dr. Christine mu ta a chief medical
officer at the American Foundation for
Suicide Prevention is with us good
morning doctor you've said this should
be declared a national health crisis why
should it be declared a national health
crisis and what exactly would that mean
well suicide has been in the top 10
leading causes of death and it is a
generally preventable cause of death and
that has been for a number of years it's
higher than the homicide rate in this
country that is correct
and as the CDC report pointed out it's
been on the rise since 1999 so I think
the issue is that as a nation we have
not been paying attention it is
happening every day every week we suffer
the tragic loss of two high-profile
individuals and yet every week 865
Americans are dying by suicide and so
again this is the moment we are ready to
pay attention people are asking the
right questions and there is a science
to inform a strategy and there is
advocacy underway I keep hearing that
suicide is a permanent problem a
permanent solution to a temporary
problem is it correct to assume that
everyone who commits suicide and you and
we'll talk about that too because I know
you all don't like that phrase correct
to assume that they have mental health
issues couldn't it be you're so stressed
about something and that you're not
mentally ill or does it mean that you
have a mental health problem one in four
Americans is living with a mental health
condition and less than half of them are
having it addressed diagnosed and
treated so think about the millions of
people also who experienced a
terrible stress loss of job
relationships dream financial strain and
war trauma don't take them and don't
even have suicidal ideation necessarily
let alone die by suicide so there have
to be other risk factors that come to
bear and mental health conditions and
and some aspects of the brain there is a
neurobiology behind suicide risk it is
complex but it is a health-related
outcome this has been looking for signs
that someone may be depressed to the
point that they may be suicidal and in
part of the reading I've learned that
there are words that people use who may
be suicidal what are those words well
when a person becomes so distressed
someone become suicidal not because they
are necessarily wanting to think about
death they're in pain they're in despair
and anguish and in that moment of
extreme distress their their cognition
actually narrows into a bit more of a
tunnel vision we think of a constricted
sort of thinking and so the the idea of
taking their life is a solution in that
moment so right so there are things like
I this is not going to get any better or
I there's no way I can change that is
right those types of thoughts I would
advise everyone to understand that we
have been socialized to hide our
distress we function through a lot and
that can be a good thing to a point and
so subtle changes in a person's behavior
will possibly tip you off and I would
trust your gut instinct you know the
people around you in your life and you
know their patterns when they're
isolating withdrawing their sleep starts
to change their drinking more using more
losing their temper more those all our
indications very likely that their
mental health could be shifting and
deteriorating what other kinds of
cultural and societal shifts have taken
place that are outside of the
neurobiological piece that we need to be
thinking about it in terms of this right
we think about this rise in the suicide
rate this comes at a time when the
American public is actually wonderfully
more open-minded about mental health
being a part of health now we need to
deepen that to a greater level of
literacy and and sort of actionable
strategies but the the societal reasons
we believe have to do with because
suicide is multifactorial so economic
Changez access to lethal means including
the opioid epidemic that we're in right
now just that infusion of an easy access
to lethal means can drive up a range
someone stopped me on the street and
said I wish you would stop saying
committed suicide because that is a
wrong thing to say
why and what should we say thank you so
much for raising that yes there have
been tremendous advocacy efforts the AP
Stylebook has changed and advises
against the phrase committed suicide
because if you think about the term
committed implies a criminal act a moral
act committed murder and and suicide has
been vastly misunderstood over the when
are we saying we should say the person
took their life died by suicide and did
his or her life plain language no
judgment well we're gonna continue this
conversation thank you so much dr. mutia
thank you